[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue la dernière de la saison
rassurez-vous guillaume roquette n'a pas
déserté il sera de retour à la rentrée
le figaro-magazine d'ailleurs et pas
paresseux week-end et ils tirent sur eux
le monde d'alix quand la bd rencontre
l'histoire et son directeur adjoint est
avec nous bonjour jean christophe lui
soit il connaît aussi bien le foot la
politique la culture l'art de vivre que
les balkans ça tombe bien on va parler
de tout ça aujourd'hui on va en parler
également avec arena temps bonjour
autres directeurs adjoints autres
rédactions marianne qui titre en
l'occurrence cette semaine sur des
champs deschamps président excellente
matière à débat avec deux autres
spécialistes de la chose je ne parle pas
de deschamps mais du football richard
bouygues provenir adjoint socialiste à
la mairie du 12e arrondissement et co
auteur du livre le foot
va-t-il exploser voulons signer le plein
d'autres publications d'ailleurs sous
votre plume et sur ce sujet auquel vous
avez contribué comme co directeur de
l'observatoire sport et sociétés de la
fondation jean jaurès je ne me trompe
pas et face à vous un enfin alexandre de
vécu aux journalistes à figaro vox on
signale d'abord votre livre les nouveaux
enfants du siècle qu'on ne se lasse pas
de lire et de relire et de citer et
votre très bonne interview dans le
figaro magazine d'eliette abécassis
plaisir des yeux plaisir de lire
puisqu'elle rend hommage
un géant de la littérature l'écrivain et
romancier américain tom wolfe décédé
comment philippe bardon vis et philip
roth pourquoi j'ai marqué tom wolfe
c'est philip roth je vous confirme un
listing des malls et voilà
et c'était à lire dans le figaro
magazine aussi donc rassurez vous on ne
parlera pas de littérature je sais pas
s'il faut se rassurer mais on la
recommande les conseils de lecture de
figaro live à retrouver dans l'anglais
juste au-dessus figaro l'ail et au fait
conseils de lecture valises pour l'été
et vous aurez plein de conseils à la une
ce soir
la france est elle mieux armées contre
le terrorisme
création d'un parc est spécifique au
grand dam des syndicats de magistrats
qui crient à l'instauration d'une
justice d'exception
est ce justifié sans jeu de mots est ce
bien sûr tout le problème
on attend vos commentaires on attend vos
réactions
la france est elle mieux armés à la
veille du 14 juillet et avec la
promulgation de la loi de programmation
militaire en face d'ailleurs avec les
exigences de l'otan un an après
l'humiliation du chef d'état-major des
armées par macron le président de la
république at il à tirer les leçons de
la crise de l'an dernier avec le haut
commandement militaire at il compris le
message
donnez-nous vos réponses votre avis et
poser vos questions on reviendra
également sur un autre sujet
l'inscription de pictogrammes sur les
dangers du vin pour les ados et les
femmes enceintes levée de boucliers de
la profession romanée conti roederer
petrus même combat même tribune dans le
figaro et même message blanc rouge rosé
ou à bulles boire du vin n'est pas un
délit enfin on ne va pas y échapper
le foot est ce que vous y croyez
est ce que les bleus ont déjà gagné
débat au sommet puisque ce débat il est
avec les invités mais avec vous puisque
vous êtes nos premiers invités et on
attend que vous répondez à nos questions
notamment sur twitter et on salue sylvie
jacqueline kevin nicole romero vous
faites tout de suite
partagez vos commentaires notamment sur
une question un peu lourde qui est une
question d'actualité le terrorisme cent
dix mille policiers et gendarmes sont
mobilisés pour assurer la sécurité à la
fois du 14 juillet est également de la
retransmission
et de la finale de la coupe du monde de
foot à partir de 17 heures dimanche deux
événements d'ailleurs qui seront à
suivre avant pendant et après sur figaro
live et alors que edouard philippe
seront à nice demain pour l'hommage aux
victimes de l'attentât du 14 juillet
2016 le premier ministre donc a présenté
ce matin un plan de lutte antiterroriste
parmi la quarantaine de mesures
annoncées certaines sont secrètes
d'autres le sont moins notamment celle
ci ce matin la création d'un parquet
national anti terroriste qui permettra
de renforcer encore vous êtes rassurés
je suis au retour assuré par les par les
chiffres qui a donné un peu edouard
philippe
lors de cette conférence de presse
notamment sur évidemment là la baisse du
nombre d'attentats terroristes s'est
donné un à zen et même si on a eu
quelques-uns est assez spectaculaire
d'une part ensuite le nombre d'attentats
avéré qu'ils ont été déjoués c'est quand
même assez rassurant et sur le faut le
souligner aussi et cette mesure ne sont
des mesures de bon sens de créer ce
parquet antiterroriste qui était de la
demande et par 2 par de nombreuses
personnalités de tous bords d'ailleurs
moi je crois que edouard philippe
emmanuel macron le gouvernement fait ce
qu'il peut dans la mesure où la loi
empêche un certain nombre de mesures qui
pourraient nous semblait plus encore
plus radicale est peut-être plus
efficace comme l'expulsion des étrangers
ou des binationaux pour des faits de
terroristes mais ça il faut changer les
lois pour arriver à ça donc pour
l'instant dans le cadre la loi telle
qu'elle existe je pense que petit à
petit il me semble que le gouvernement
fait ce qu'il peut et surtout il
s'adapte à la modification de la menace
que fait peser
l'état islamique en france puisque ayant
perdu en partie du territoire qui avait
conquis ces dernières années évidemment
lui-même change sa forme de combat et
nous sommes obligés eux aussi de
modifier notre façon de nous défendre
la dernière chose qui m'a un petit peu
agacé ses 7,7 communication c'est à dire
il ya quarante mesures y en a 8 ans vous
dis pas ça c'est quand même c'est je
trouve ça ridicule c'est évidemment
qu'elles aient mesures qui sont pas dit
qui sont secrètes on espère qu'il ya des
choses qui ne sont pas dévoilées dans la
transparence totale aux citoyens pour
gérer la sécurité des français meilleur
ce besoin de dire mais on a plein de
botte secrète cachée meurt oubliera pas
je trouve ça un petit peu puéril et
enfantin c'est ce que c'est votre avis
également
j'ai un peu un invité différent je suis
d'accord avec l'analyse mais je crains
le coup de com en même temps que le plan
antiterroriste pourquoi parce que ça me
rappelle un peu la task force qui avait
été annoncé avec un grand renfort
médiatique et qui au final ne s'est pas
avérée quand même être l'outil qu'on
attendait même les personnes qui
participent aujourd'hui sont un petit
peu plus interrogatifs sur l'outil tel
qu'il a évolué ce qu'il est devenu
est ce que finalement l'ensemble de ce
plan qui pour une grande partie
d'ailleurs prolonge des actions qui ont
été aidées mesures décidées alors du
quinquennat précédent
est ce que ce plan est à la hauteur je
sais pas en tout cas je trouve que la
mesure la plus intéressante est
peut-être celle dont on parle le moins
mois le parquet national jeu je
m'interroge parce que oui mais là mais
la mesure la mesure c'est celle qui
concerne notamment les sorties de prison
d'individus qui sont radicalisées oui
qu'on est tous qu'on était déjà condamné
pour terrorisme je crois que c'est 450
le nombre dont 50 qui sont eux condamnés
pour terrorisme
là par contre il me semble qu'ils aient
un véritable enjeu est derrière qui ne
concerne pas que la france c'est une
dimension que d'autres pays connaissent
aujourd'hui ray charles
oui qu'est-ce qui vous a plu dans la
mesure cap l'élu local gouvernement
parce que je trouve que sur les mesures
d'accompagnement dans les sorties je
crois qu'il ya véritablement quelque
chose à faire ils veulent aujourd'hui
très une mesure spécifique pour
accompagner et mieux accompagner ces
personnes
l'observation n'y a pas que
l'observation il ya un meilleur
accompagnement ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui est nouveau qui
concerne la france mais pas que la
france et d'autres pays européens
on parle de pays dans les balkans toute
valeur mais ils sont aussi confrontés je
crois que c'est la bosnie notamment qui
vit ça d'une manière particulière bref
je pense qu'il ya un véritable enjeu qui
n'est pas d'art français qui est à la
fois européen et cette mesure je pense
aller un peu trop
un ministre
le 6e rang alors qu'elle me semble être
peut-être l'aspect le plus nouveau même
si pas forcément le mieux mises en
exergue dans la communication du
gouvernement
je suis d'accord sur les mesures enfin
bon on aurait pu entendre des choses
sans forcément avoir caché comme ça
c'est pour ça que ça renforce un petit
peu tout les initiales du côté comme ça
mérite et je crois un petit peu plus
parce que c'est un enjeu partagé parfois
être quand même un peu claires le plan
de lutte contre le terrorisme n'est pas
à la hauteur c'est ce que nous dit
sylvie romero dit plus d'ailleurs
pourquoi selon vous il n'est pas à la
hauteur
et pour vous alexandre il est à la
hauteur moi je pose que c'est quand même
une évolution significative ya des
choses effectivement intéressante ce qui
vient d'être dit notamment je pense que
d'ailleurs le gouvernement ne communique
pas plus parce qu'il risque d'être
accusé de mener une politique
liberticide notamment c'est quand même
une révolution philosophique
théoriquement quand on a changé notre
peine on a plongé aussi notre dette pour
la société là les gens vont continuer à
être observées donc on tient compte de
la spécificité de cette menace demeure
sa gêne pas en tout cas certains
internautes pascal hamon s'est dit en
guerre et que la discrétion du basque
nous dit on est en guerre on doit avoir
des lois d'exception
oui je pense que c'est pour la première
fois on n'a personne n'ose le dire mais
réellement des lois d'exception
je pense que un parc et la nationale
spécialisée c'est aussi une bonne chose
puisque c'est effectivement des cas
extrêmement spécifique il faudrait pas
qu'on se retrouve à nouveau avec je
rappelle par exemple que l'assassin du
du père abel avait été libéré avec
bracelet électronique
donc là il ya une forme de légèreté des
juges qui visiblement n'avait pas
compris la spécificité de cette menace
là donc sur le plan sécuritaire ça me
paraît intéressant ensuite je pense que
le combat contre le terrorisme ne doit
pas cacher le combat plus profond qu'on
a amené à mon avis ce sera le combat
d'une génération contre contre
l'islamisme derrière le terroriste il ya
une idéologie qui se répondent notamment
dans certains quartiers qui est pas loin
d'être peut-être pas majoritaire chez
les
mais en proportion importante et je
pense que le combat du futur c'est celui
ci ça passe par là délai à l'éducation
ça passe par la maîtrise des flux
migratoires ça passe par le retour d'une
forme de patriotisme et c'est ce combat
là aussi qu'il vous faudra mener dans
les décennies prochaine est ce que vous
êtes ce que vous partagez d'ailleurs
l'avis que vient d'exprimer alexandre ii
vecchio bien vous ne vous continuez à
nous le dire sur le forum du figaro sur
facebook également on our vous a posé
une question sur twitter êtes vous
convaincu du nouveau plan de lutte
contre le terrorisme présenté par
edwards fut dit philippe et vous êtes
82% à nous répondre non est ce que c'est
votre cas est ce que vous partagez cette
scepticisme et relais mais non je suis
pas sceptique moi je trouve que le
gouvernement en fait l'appareil d'état
en général font quand même leur travail
fait d'une certaine manière c'est vrai
le bilan tel qu'il a été dit avant moi
c'est que ça a baissé
c'est qu'il ya moins d'attaqués il ya
moins d'attaqués réussies et même il
semble même volonté d'attaquer aux
menaces mais moi je pense qu'on est
peut-être en train de changer d'un petit
aussi l'époque c'est à dire que d'une
part les sanctuaires extérieur dèche
notamment aux scieries sont en train
d'être détruit
donc la menace est en train de changer
peut-être qu'elle diminue aussi parce
que les bases arrières sont moins
conséquente est pas si simple comme ça
si j'ai pas dire ils ont mis des gens
ils ont disséminé des gens et puis ces
gens m'ont attaqué ce n'est pas aussi
simple que ça et deuxièmement commence à
être nous enfin les pays qui ont été
frappés par le terrorisme qui sont qui
se sont confrontés au terrorisme sont
comment ça va être confronté à une
deuxième époque
par exemple on doit gérer à la fois les
sorties de prison mais aussi le retour
de familles d'enfants des épouses
éventuellement d'hommes sur le
territoire national la russie fait de
magna investirait
intéressant article on voit que en
tchétchénie on accueille le espèce de
demi dictateur à ces sanguinaires qui a
mis qui a réussi à régler le problème
tchétchène kirov devient maintenant le
champion d'une d'aného islamisme qui
serait non terroriste en accueillant les
familles des gens des choses et beaucoup
de choses très compliquées comme ça
qu'il va falloir gérer et là pour le
coup c'est vraiment action anti charlie
hebdo d'un s'éteint c'est un travail
d'une génération
le travail de police et une génération
un trail du justin génération les
solutions simplistes
d'ailleurs à mon avis soulèverait le
même scepticisme de la population par
exemple on dans les solutions de
simpliste par exemple expulser tous les
tous les anciens terroristes notamment
les binationaux bande 1,4 pratique là en
ce moment là on n'a jamais levé gala
djamel beghal m'incombe hier accélérant
rappellent qu'ils aient jamais le gall
et les a invités dans le saint des
attentats de dans des attentats de 95
les alimenteurs d'un des frères quoi je
sers toi filiale de coulibaly dont
twitter de charlie de l'attentât contre
charlie hebdo et koulibaly contre
l'hyper cacher la sorte de prison dix
ans dix ans dix ans de prison
fan plein essor il a été déchu de sa
nationalité puisqu'il était franco
algérien déchu sa natalité comme quoi
c'est possible
tous les trucs qui dit et tout les
toutes les personnes qui ont dit on ne
peut pas il faut changer le droit voire
changer la constitution
c'était tout ça dr françois fillon
l'avait dit le premier à voir dit
écoutez tout ça ça existe déjà il
s'appelle elle pourra lui rendre hommage
au moins de temps en temps c'est
françois fillon et france info rendu
hommage à françois fillon c'est pour ça
que point de vue existent c'est pour ce
genre d'habillage qui sont parfois assez
inattendu non on se fie aux elle avait
rappelé donc voila et bien on se
retrouve un cas concret c'est que vous
êtes drame algérien ils ont fait le port
et quand le moment on va être obligé
avec soin les on va essayer de briques
au québec c'est le show il va être
maintenue à résidence avec un bracelet
sont sous surveillance sa du ca doit
correspondre aussi à la tâche de cette
chute
ces deux cellules qui vient d'être
annoncée on fait quoi on cède aux
algériens mais les algériens non mais
vous le savez le gac dans l'histoire
c'est qu'en fait les avocats de djamel
beghal ils vont devoir aller plaider
alger devant le tribunal administratif
algérois algérien pardon pour faire
condamner l'état algérien pour non
reconnaissance de la nationalité puisque
vrai jeu
je crois savoir que l'algérie a signé
les mêmes conventions que nous le
conseil national qui disent qu'on ne
peut pas faire on ne peut pas déchoir
les gens de nationalité d'origine
donc les algériens peuvent pas faire un
apatride nous n'avons pas le droit de
faire les apatrides pour ça que la
déchéance de nationalité ne peut pas
conseil ne peut concerner que des gens
qui ont une double nationalité
et donc il fait la même chose pour
l'algérie donc les algériens certains y
aura un jour dans les semaines les mois
les années qui viennent un procès alger
pour obliger l'état algérien à reprendre
djamel beghal parce que ce serait une
bonne chose il nous faut il faut
renvoyer dans leur pays d'origine tout
les binationaux fichiers vous croyez
vous que les pays qui ont subi que
l'algérie a suivi une guerre civile
épouvantable et à côté desquels des
attentats de chez nous j pas que c'est
une plaisanterie c'est s était c'était
horrible puisque en plus moi j'étais à
côté donc je sais de quoi je parle
mais franchement il ya eu 100 milles
sans mutu en algérie qui le croyaient
que l'état algérien ils ont vraiment
envie de voir arriver de chamelle dégâts
c'était franchement c'est intéressant
parce que ce que ce que dire maintenant
on attend c'est de constater qu'il ya
des zones grises dans le combat à la fin
que le combat contre l'islamisme pour
autant dire ce que vous dites pas rien
aujourd'hui quand on veut expulser des
gens qui sont expulsables
par exemple au pakistan on ne peut pas
parce que le pakistan ne veut pas donc
on a beau ils ont beau être excusés ne
peut pas les renvoyer au pakistan et
alors là c'est un problème des migrants
et un premier terrorisme celui qui vient
d'être évoquée mais en france pour
revenir sur ces voiliers sur le jour et
d'objets des zones cno fonctionnaires de
quitter passage
ici qui disait que parfois il faut six
cantons fait pression sur les pays
d'origine finalement ils finissent par
morcenais donc alors les questions de
migration et santé rassure quand même
pas tout à fait sont épanouis les zones
rice et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les
mosquées salafistes aujourd'hui en
france à ce qu'on les ferme est ce qu'on
est sympa pour l'instant apparemment on
ne les ferme pas alors qu'il ya des
choses qui sont dites et qui fait à
l'envers notamment à la sphère du de
l'imam abdul faut absolument la leçon qu
en tisane la lutte contre les essentiels
contre la propagande islamiste et sur
internet
on ne peut pas dans le cadre de la loi
prendre certaines mesures sur internet
donc aider une zone grise comme ça tous
les gouvernements du monde avec tous les
efforts du monde dans le cas d'élèves
actuels ne peuvent rien faire et ces
zones grises qui sont inquiétants que la
loi peut toujours changer je pense et on
re découvrir que là que la politique
c'est de voir des rapports de force
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit il ya des
moyens de mettre la pression sur
l'algérie des sanctions économiques
possibles
on peut y réfléchir sans politique de
faire de la politique d'assumer une
forme de rapport de forces c'est ce qui
se passe aux etats-unis avec donald
trump peut-être pour le pire et pour le
meilleur mais ça a l'air de lui réussir
dans les sondages parce que les citoyens
s'y retrouver il applique le programme
pour lequel il a été élu ça pose est est
également là la question de la dérive du
droit aujourd'hui il ya un certain
nombre d'instances supranationales
d'instance juridique qui empiète à mon
avis sur sur le politique et je pense
qu'il faut rééquilibrer un peu plus en
faveur du politique un peu moins de
droits un peu moins de deux juridictions
et un peu plus de politique êtes vous
convaincu du nouveau plan de lutte
contre le terrorisme présenté par
edouard philippe c'est la question qu'on
vous pose sur twitter hashtag point de
vue est pour l'instant vous êtes
toujours une écrasante majorité à
répondre non benoît nous dit
il faut que les collectivités locales
maires etc soit directement informé par
les services secrets sur les fiches et s
dans leur ville pour mieux les gérer et
surveiller alors st c'est une des
mesures qui prévues dans le plan de
lutte antiterroriste de pouvoir prévenir
en toute confidentialité
un certain nombre de maires de la
présence d'un milieu dangereux on passe
quand même de quelque chose où il y
avait quasiment rien à quelque chose on
va donner des informations mais sans
bien évidemment tout dévoiler l'idée
n'est pas que à un moment donné l'état
confie aux élus locaux l'ensemble des
données par contre ne rien avoir et
parfois un peu surprenant quand on est
un élu local
et quand on apprend à postériori parce
que vous êtes arrivé d'ailleurs dans le
deuxième mais c'est à nous et à mais ça
nous est arrivé dans ça nous est arrivé
dans le xiième effectivement où on a été
confronté à un individu qui a été arrêté
en possession d'une arme blanche sur un
espace public et qui est visiblement
suivi qui était un individu fichiers
pour lequel bien évidemment nous
n'avions aucune voit aucun aucun élément
aucun a aucune indication entre ne rien
avoir
et puis avoir l'ensemble des données qui
d'après moi ne sont pas de la
responsabilité du maire et que le maire
n'a pas à voir je pense qu'il ya un
juste milieu à trouver et je pense que
sur ce point là on devrait avec le
gouvernement trouvé cette ce point
d'équilibré
je le dis pourquoi parce que entre ceux
qui demandent tous je pense que c'est
vraiment dangereux et le fait qu'on ait
rien il ya une zone qui est un petit peu
compliqué pour des élus locaux a à gérer
notamment quand on est en équipe
municipale et en responsabilité mais
vis-à-vis de la population aussi qui
nous interpelle sur ces sujets donc je
crois qu'il ya quelque chose à trouver
petit point sur le parquet national anti
taurine moi la chose qui m'a un peu gêné
au delà des débats syndicat de la
magistrature ou pas est un débat qui a
déjà eu lieu depuis quelques années c
est ce qu on rajoute ou pas dans les
compétences la lutte sur le grand
banditisme la grande corruption etc
parce qu'on sait qu'à un moment donné
le lien avec le terrorisme et le grand
banditisme n'est pas complètement à
chaque fois des nuées pourquoi enlever
alors que ça a pu être un moment donné
un des sujets d'expertisé que ça me
semble pas idiot de le laisser il faut
que les collectivités locales donc soit
directement informée ça on l'a vu il y à
une autre une autre marque nous fait
pascal en tout cas une opinion qu'elle
exprime tant que les juges mettront les
trois en avant toujours l'état de droit
on n'y arrivera pas j'étais sûr
correspond pas ou en tout cas plus haut
c'est la réalité de l'exercice de la
justice d qui saisit terrorisme voilà je
pense que c'est il ya plus de l'accident
a trouvé un juge de l'accident un
dossier terrorisme sdat récemment dans
l'est depuis un an ou deux je pense que
photo je ne me gêne je n'ai pas vu la
presse en tout cas sortir un seul cas
sauf la libération depuis la libération
effectivement je rappelle une fois que
l'acte commis est sans doute une
sévérité mais marcel à la personne et
fichiers elle s'est signalée par ses
plus hauts niveaux de la pire soirée
l'administrateur pratiquer la justice
qui était laxiste la sécurité actuelle
n'est pas assurée contre le terrorisme
estime jean-claude il faut que macro et
philippaerts être leur déni de la
situation sow pagis un certain nombre
d'attentes avec m'en étais content et
des jouets et peut-être même plus mais
on considère qu'il ne méritait pas
d'être signalé je pense que je moi je
pense faut pas faire le procès
faut pas faire procès inverse l'exécutif
parce que s'ils n'en font pas trop s'ils
n'en ont pas trop où en terme de
communication
je trouve que peut-être qu'il faut
l'avancé en savoir gré plutôt que de le
critiquer parce que qu'est-ce que c'est
quoi l'inversé faire beaucoup de tam tam
et de regarder alors il arrive au lieu
du premier ministre a été pris dans la
république au lieu d'être en grande
banlieue parisienne ça aurait été à
l'elysée on aurait fait une conférence
on aura habitait même chose et ils
auraient ils prennent la république
aurait pu dire regardez ce que je fais
voilà je trouve que certaines mais je
veux dire ce nas c'est la communication
tue le tue le sujet chaud que la loi le
gouvernement il est dans son rôle et un
bon équilibre entre l'action et la
communication par contre edel lui
reprocher c'était quand même eu des
attentats
dernièrement pas si longtemps à paris il
ya quelques à quelques rides ici et j'ai
eu le sentiment que justice qui si
l'exécutif tente est presque une
stratégie de la banalisation en moi je
m'habitue rajab est ce que des gens se
fassent et égorgée dans les rues même si
c'est plus 400 personnes qui se font
tuer comme au bataclan que c'est une
personne c'est déjà de trop et on en
restera là et avec cette également cette
remarque denis qu'il faut respecter
l'état de droit mais juste ne plus faire
preuve de laxisme et de collusion avec
l'islam radical ça correspondait à ce
que disait à ce que lisent et alexandre
ii vecchio mais je note votre satisfecit
général au gouvernement sur ce plan de
lutte antiterroriste je ne me laisserai
pas baiser comme ça c'était il ya un an
c'était ce qu'avait déclaré le chef
d'état major des armées
en pleine offensive de bercy contre le
budget de la défense emmanuel macron
avait pris la mouche à la et avait cru
opportun souvenez vous de réagir comme
ça il ne m'a pas échappé que ces
derniers jours ont été marqués par de
nombreux débats sur le sujet du budget
de la défense
je considère pour ma part il n'est pas
digne d'étaler certain débat sur la
place publique
j'ai pris des engagements je suis votre
chef
les engagements que je prends devant nos
concitoyens et devant des armées je sais
les tenir et je n'ai à cet égard besoin
2000 pression et deux nuls commentaire
on reviendra sur non pas des
commentaires mais les réactions de nos
invités quand ils écoutent cette
déclaration le chef d'état major des
armées à l'époque n'avait pas commenté
il avait juste agi ou plus exactement
réagi par le geste
ainsi puisqu'il avait démissionné sous
les applaudissements de ses troupes à
l'état majeur à la l'état-major de
balard
par ce geste son but c'était que l'état
conserve mais surtout augmente le budget
des armées
objectif 2 % du pib
depuis une nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire a été votée et elle a été
promulguée ce matin et le président de
la république l'a fondée sur une
conviction c'est cette conviction qui
m'a conduit à m'engager sur une
trajectoire budgétaire qui permettra de
porter l'effort de défense à 2% du
produit intérieur brut en 2025 afin de
continuer à conduire les opérations là
où nous devons les mener à préparer
l'avenir et à moderniser les équipements
maquereau a compris il semblait avoir
compris
après on verra ce que les lois de
programmation militaire
ça existe depuis le début de la 5eme
vème république
dites moi aucune n'a été mené à son
terme dans les termes dans lesquels
étaient au départ
en général c'est toujours en dessous
pourquoi parce que cela il ya un vrai
enjeu est un véritable enjeu d'autant
qu' il ya une heure par maya non
seulement on manque de crédit mais en
plus il ya quelques erreurs stratégiques
ont été faites par exemple on a trop
longtemps
privilégiez un avion supériorité
stratégique au détriment de la
production de drones et de quoi est ce
qu'on s'est aperçu qu'on a besoin quand
on est dans le c'est ce qu'on a besoin
de drones et ceux dont donc l'armée
française dans son combat contre le
terrorisme contre les salafistes les
terroristes au mali est passé de drones
conquis ont désormais deux drones armés
que les américains élisent ralliant
produisent depuis belle lurette
maintenant et que l'europe la france et
les européens sont incapables pour nos
mondes produit on attend peut-être un
drone et romain d'origine étrangère show
américain va être armé bientôt mais
seulement bientôt mais c'est pas un
drone produit des projets des projets en
fait de coopération progrès andp
république avait promis le premier geste
du président de la république en tant
que chef des armées c'est pas celui là
c'est d'être allé au mali rencontrer les
troupes et là bas et leur a promis
c'était assez discret parce que y avait
une polémique sur la place des
journalistes qui avaient défrayé enfin
qui avait fait couler beaucoup d'encre
mais il avait fait une promesse aux
troupes sur place c'est de leur fournir
des blindés
capable d'évoluer dans le désert et qui
avait suffisamment blindés pour les
protéger contre les et les bombes
artisanales
je pense qu'ils attendent toujours je
pense que les troupes dans le désert ils
ont toujours pas ce fameux blindé qui
leur manque tant parce que pour le coup
ça c'est quelque chose dont les soldats
ont vraiment besoin et s'il l'a fait
c'est qui est bien aussi c'est une très
bonne idée qu'elle prétend la public qui
semblait avoir compris bien pour le
moment en tout cas à ma connaissance
j'ai vu encore que les chez les
états-majors demandé à avoir des espèces
de 4 4 qui écoule un qui était capable
d'aller aussi vite que les formats quoi
un format quoi tu sais enfin il manque
de beaucoup de choses
voilà et la pratique de la guerre c'est
ça c'est une des choses assez c'est pas
seulement des milliards c'est des choses
assez concrète zucchi un décalage entre
l'effet d'annoncé puis les puits les
résultats de cette loi de programmation
militaire de plusieurs centaines de
milliards sur ce 300 milliards
sur sept ans je crois ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'aujourd'hui au mali pour
repenser et ayant s'ils sont un régal
vote contre 30 ans l'âge parce que c'est
une règle générale dans l'armée
française on a d un matériel est très
vieillissant qui n'a pas été renouvelé
ces dernières années et dont on paye
aujourd'hui le prix maintenant qu'on est
engagé sur des conflits réels ensuite
macron à ce qu'il a compris je crois que
oui je crois que au sein de l'armée sa
cote a considérablement remonté
notamment au niveau de l'état major
parce qu'il a pris des mesures notamment
vis-à-vis des familles puisque c'est la
situation des familles de militaires a
catastrophique depuis des mois ils sont
ils sont physiquement épuisés lorsqu'ils
sont lorsqu'ils reviennent opérations
militaires ils font du sentinel
donc ils n'ont même plus de temps pour
l'entraînement il ya plus de moyens pour
l'entraînement donc nous sommes amenés
en état de faire la guerre donc il ya un
cercle vicieux qui qu'il faut arriver à
et ça je crois que macro on a pris la
mesure il ya des mesures voilà les
drones armés vont s'allier s'était
décidée c'est peut-être tardif c'est pas
en huit jours que tout ça va se faire
mais je pense qu'il a compris mais le
problème c'est vraiment les soldats de
base encore une fois c'est des choses
tout ça mais les soldats de base quand
vous leur parlez c'est un problème de
tri de vêtements d'un quotidien de gilet
pare-balles et tout ça ça prend du temps
ça prend de l'argent ça prend de
l'énergie et ça on n'en verra pas les
effets tout de suite donc il y aura
toujours un décalage demain on va saluer
revoir que le défilé du 14 juillet ça va
être magnifique comme d'habitude c'est
toujours un peu l'arbre qui cache la
forêt mais le quotidien des soldats mais
quelque chose de très de très frappant
au sein de l'armée française qui est qui
peut signaler alors que ça intéresserait
des sociologues je pense que emmanuel
todd c'est le passionnait c'est le nom
des divorces qui a augmenté
considérablement au sein de au sein des
familles de militaires qui sont
traditionnellement des familles qui
divorce peut on fait beaucoup d'enfants
et ça augmente et pourquoi parce que les
familles sont épuisés par ce rythme
depuis trois quatre ans depuis la montée
du théorie donc ça c'était vraiment des
détails mais qui participe d'une des
nanosphères alors que vous regardez tous
les sondages c'est 90% des français
plébiscitent l'armée française à une
réconciliation nationale au tourne
autour de l'armée l'abordage
proportionnel à celui pour les
journalistes aussi un média
c'est le chiffre reste à faire 300
milliards ces deux langages et vous
engager ou 300 milliards c'est donc le
chiffre de sept clubs programmation sens
bien c'est bien confirmé richard houis
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il y avait eu
un effort de fait enfin c'est même pas
l'impression sais je sais qu'il ya eu un
effort de fait pendant le quinquennat
précédent et qu'on est dans la
continuité on a augmenté un peu vite
devenir quinquennat précédent
mais bon il faut quand on peut le
réhabiliter c'est pas mal et sur ces
deux points là tout casser et on a dit
du bien de fonctionnement pour qu'on
dise bien sûr mais j'ai pas fait
d'exiger pas dit du bien de françois
hollande ou d'un autre je dis que
simplement les mesures qu'on a sur le
terrorisme on les avait déjà prises et
elles sont d'autant plus importants dans
le quinquennat précédent que là où on
est dans la continuité de ce qui a été
les bouleversements précédent c'était
bien plus important sur le terrorisme
dans le précédent quinquennat
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
continuité on n'a pas les
bouleversements qu'on a eue sur la la le
budget de la défense a aidé les arrêts
des armées on peut dire que l'engagement
et a été pris déjà dans le quinquennat
précédent on a deux on est passé en gros
de 31,4 milliards à 33 milliards c'est
ça par an ça va être en gros ça donc oui
on a augmenté vous avez raison mais dire
qu'il n'a pas été pris en compte cet
engagement dans le caca la présence est
là où je sais juste une précision ce qui
est vrai c'est dans ce que vous dites
d'abord je vous rassure il y a été dit
même ici du bien de france au médicament
d'alors marc landré sur la question sur
le choc de compétitivité premier
premiers points est 2e
deuxième point même de effectivement
ce à quoi vous faites allusion justement
sur la suite du quinquennat précédent
sur l'augmentation des crédits
militaires c'est le lendemain sur le
discours de françois hollande ray au
congrès au lendemain du discours sur os
au lendemain des attentats du bataclan à
paris
mais précédemment le budget au début du
quinquennat sous jean yves le drian
avait encore plus fort sur nicolas saint
tin oo pensée militaire il avait baissé
à cause de la crise économique dure je
rappelle quand même ce fou se souvient
gpp il y avait encore une suppression
enfin ce que ce que je dis c'est que on
est un nombre donné oui il ya un effort
mais cet effort il a été d'abord engagé
dans le quinquennat précédent on le
poursuit et c'est très bien
après est-ce que macron a tout compris
probablement parce que c'est un as de la
communication dans la loi de
programmation militaire il ya quand même
eu des petits moments ont été des
pierres d'achoppement le service
national universel ça a quand même un
petit peu crispé dans les casernes pour
le dire avec des grands guillemets mais
ça n'a pas été forcément non mais au
départ il était prévu pour avoir une
vocation militaire il a été sorti de la
loi de programmation militaire sur les
opex et notamment le sur le surcoût des
opex
jusqu'à présent on avait eu une
interministérielle it et pour prendre en
compte ce surcoût aujourd'hui c'est le
budget de la défense qui va le prendre
c'est quoi ces 850 millions bon c'est
des points drame qui sont aujourd'hui
sur la table
et est ce que ce qui s'est passé la vire
au début le péché originel
est-ce que c'est dépassé moi je ne pense
pas je pense qu'aujourd'hui par contre
ça une volonté du gouvernement
effectivement d'apaiser la situation
mais les rancoeurs elles existent encore
et même si c'est les chefs d'état-major
vous le disiez ça peut aujourd'hui être
un satisfécit un peu plus pour à la fois
les soldats sur le terrain ça ne l'est
pas nécessairement il ya quand même une
grande interrogation sur l'orientation
qui est donnée auprès de auprès de la
hiérarchie et ses deux points montre
qu'à un moment donné ça n'a pas
forcément fonctionner dans le dialogue
et qu'il ya eu à un moment une
crispation et achoppement d'autant que
une grande partie de l'effort enfin moi
je veux bien qu'on fasse c'est qu'on
dise que tout est bien mais une grande
partie de l'effort c'est quand même
poste quinquennat actuel ans c'est vrai
d'ailleurs de la révision de la
précédente loi de programmation
militaire
ce que subit notre excellent temps soeur
nathalie guibert du monde à cette époque
là
macron ne répond qu'aux demandes
militaire des etats unis c'est ce que
nous dit arnaud sur lefigaro.fr
on pose la question sur twitter
d'ailleurs selon la france vous la
france est elle suffisamment armé pour
faire face aux conflits dans lesquels
elle est engagée vous répondez non à 68%
ont continué à nous dire pourquoi
beaucoup d'internautes sur lefigaro.fr
se demande au final d'ailleurs si la
france encore un budget conséquent pour
se défendre c'est toute la question
cyber guerre informatique nous dit wak
doc sur lefigaro.fr la france est en
retard pour se défendre notamment sur
cette question là il y aura d'ailleurs
dès demain des des militaires qui sont
engagés dans cette cyberguerre qui sont
commandés par le colonel de paille le
général de paillerets qui
défileront sur les champs-elysées je
pense pas que la france réponde aux
exigences de donald trump parce qu'elle
est plutôt une bonne élève dans l'otan
je crois que donald trump souhaite que
ce soit 2% du budget des états on est à
1,8 l'an 2025 1 2% et cela dit moi je
sois plus ambitieuse et que l en face à
un avantage stratégique skis et ski et
manca emmanuel macron c'est une vision
stratégique je pense qu'on va avoir
besoin de la défense française vu les
nouvelles menaces en europe et qui
serait malin d'extraire le budget de la
défense du budget global de négocier ça
avec avec bruxelles sur la question des
3% à un moment donné il va falloir
choisir entre les logiques comptables et
les impératifs nationaux et là je crois
qu'il ya justement parler du roi par de
force tout à l'heure il serait peut-être
temps d'en établir avec allemagne il
sera ainsi tant que les autres nations
européennes nous aide dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
c'est ça c'est ça aussi c'est la
position que j'ai prise en main quand je
veux juste rappeler quelques faits juste
rappeler quelque chose s'il ya une
attrition effectivement des moyens c'est
d'abord parce qu'il ya une crise
économique majeure à partir de 2007
c'est-à-dire les 5 ou les dix années de
crise se sont traduits par des déficits
considérables qu'on est que
effectivement nos amis a créé les cris
de la défense comme d'accord séquence
atterrissage quand même il ya une autre
bon ça c'est déjà et donc on est en
train de sortir de ces années la
croissance revient cette fois les choses
sous un petit peu avant la crise en 2007
on est et on était les crédits de la
défense des sens des aiguilles en train
de sortir de là on y attend
effectivement depuis le geste de
françois hollande le 14 novembre
parce que c'est un geste politique faux
souvenirs déclaration est dit le le
devoir de jeu je cherche là il dit la
défense leur trouvent là des voix là il
ya la défense nationale et supérieur le
pacte de sécurité supérieur au pacte de
stabilité
l'aïe dit donc ça veut dire c'est ça les
plus opposable est donc là les questions
de défense sont supérieurs aux pressions
aux priorités que nous avons avec nous
c'est évident il s'interresse est juste
la politique là était très important et
ça a permis aux prix dans ma peau
aujourd'hui de dire aux allons
maintenant on va faire des morts on va
faire des moyens de défense en commun
donc vous allez payer plus cher alors
c'est une manière de contourner la
proposition qui est de dire ans on
devient peut-être continuera de voir si
justement c'est suivi d'effet webdocs
s'inquiète de la marine française on ne
surveille pas nos eaux selon lui et bien
on verra ça justement on reviendra sur
ces questions là à la rentrée
autre question là on n'est plus dans
l'eau mais dans le vin c'est une tribune
avec les meilleures bouteilles qui fait
la une du figaro yquem smith lafitte
puis nîmes en a chez rogers 60 meilleurs
crus en veulent à agnès buzyn ce que
vous laissez faire vous voyez c'est là
que vous pouvez lire c'est la
transformation d'un produit d'excellence
distribuée dans le monde entier en un
bien délictueux à travers la position de
pictogrammes mortifère sur les femmes
enceintes et les mineurs voici donc ce
que dit cette tribune notamment en cause
l'agrandissement en fait d'un
pictogramme qui est obligatoire depuis
une dizaine d'années qui montre que le
vin est dangereux pour les femmes
enceintes
actuellement il est d'un demi centimètre
et il doit être sa taille doit être
augmentée à plus d'un centimètre
une signalétique lugubre mortifère qui
nous associe à des substances mortifère
disent donc les auteurs de la tribune
bref le ruinart bordeaux blanc associé
au lsd voilà en tout cas la
justification de la ministre je crois
que les femmes enceintes ne savent pas
qu'aujourd'hui l'alcool passe
directement le placenta et vont
alcoolisées
le bébé ça ne viendrait à l'esprit de
personne de matt de l'alcool dans un
biberon or quand on boit de l'alcool et
qu'on est enceinte
eh bien on nourrit son bébé son site us
d'alcool et donc je pense que là il ya
une longue sur toutes les bouteilles
femmes enceintes qui existent déjà qui
exulte fille mais qui sera que personne
de parti sera plus grand nous négocions
hervé nathan bas alors là ça vous met de
l'ambiance
hervé nathan vous êtes 20 ou bien je
suis 20 et busin et je pense que même
dans ses points de vue on prend un but
ici pour une fois pour une fois pour
cette fois sur ce sujet là c'est madame
10 1 qui a raison pour deux raisons
d'abord je suis allé voir sur les fils
le site figaro point santé parce que je
connais pas très bien le cigare au point
son excellente habitude acceptant des
mollahs et donc à des résultats sérieux
dit exactement ce que dit madame busin
et donne tous les arguments d'un besoin
c'est un c'est très dangereux pour les
femmes non pas pour les femmes enceintes
et pour le bébé à venir voilà et les
statistiques les études scientifiques
vont toutes dans le même sens il n'ya
pas de dose minimale il bat dose maximum
et c'est ce que voilà la mer le foetus
la boisse et le sud moi j'ai emmenée
élise et là ça qu'on reproche non mais
le reproche je crois que les cinq
enceintes ne savent pas mais c'est ça
qu'il faut revenir à man et bien je
crois que les femmes savent c'est bien
la preuve que non parce que voilà
la prévention est la prévention santé
leur ailleurs je vais voilà l'autre
sujet moi j'ai vu le sujet qui est passé
je me suis rappelé la propagande des
fabricants de tabac c'est exactement la
même c'était exactement dumas steve
c'était vous présenter un produit qui
était un produit sympathie qui permet
l'art et la création que tout le monde
l'utilisé terrain vous présenter ça
comme un danger oui l'alcool pour les
fours les foetus c'est très dangereux
c'est très dangereux voilà et donc il
faut faire en sorte que les femmes
enceintes et allaitantes ailleurs
enceintes et allaitantes je rappelle le
figaro présente et s'abstiennent
totalement de boire parce que la
recommandation du site sans fil hier au
point santé c'est abstinence complète
c'est pas on peut en voir un petit peu
léon c'est zéro voilà et donc moi je lis
en tant que lecteur du figaro point
santé préfet je trouve que c'est il faut
il veut
voilà ce que propose d'élargir votre
votre lecture au figaro magazine et
donner la même chose que les femmes
enceintes soient interdits de lecture de
certains ouvrages jeu pourquoi de
rabelais de balzac de flaubert soit
interdit de regarder certains tableaux
on voit des bouteilles il n'y a pas de
pictos disant que les femmes enceintes
ne doivent pas avoir de 20 on est quand
même dans une société avec ce principe
de précaution inscrit dans la
constitution mais qui prend une ampleur
démesurée parce que c'est très bien mais
on arrête ou le curseur de dire que le
vin est dangereux pour les femmes
enceintes il faut le mettre partout en
ce moment partout encore d'accord dans
la littérature dans les arts dans le
cinéma en plus peut faire un film comme
cédric klapisch par exemple non mais par
exemple on est en train d'interdire le
cap en nature en train de limiter la
vitesse à 80 km/heure et par exemple
pourrait prendre une mesure qui vivent
sans doute ferez baisser nettement la
mortalité sur les routes c'est
l'interdiction totale de l'alcool on
entend pendant qu'on % des tués ont 30%
des totalement interdite voilà ça
n'empêche pas les gens de boire de
l'alcool quand ils ont envie mais pas en
conduisant est bien desservi mais là il
s'agit pas d'interdiction c'est un
pictogramme c'est une information que
vous être contre la formation alors que
nous faisons le métier d'informer je
voulais que mon espoir du versant civil
passe armée nation c'est une émission
des internautes mais là je le rappelle
est en train de défendre les lits les
plus gros groupes mondialisés de 68 dont
on parle des 68 sentons pas le font tous
leur chiffre d'affaires à l'extérieur du
pays d'ailleurs leur argumentaire c'est
de dire laissez nous participe au festin
de la mondialisation nous empêcher de
surtout pas mais les français ne peuvent
plus payer ses valeurs une fois qu'on
dévoile le château yquem personnes par
mois en france où quasiment pas oui donc
allez on va voir ça vous vous défendez
les profits au départ mais de l'avis de
la santé attend assis je veux bien tout
ce qu'ils meurent à 2 kg et je veux bien
moi pierre il ya quelques femmes
enceintes qui ne sont pas au courant
voilà la raison problèmes d'éducation
quand même ça prend l'airé des
civilisations et c'est pas la taille du
pictogramme qui va le résoudre et encore
moins sur les grands crus parce que
franchement on offre à marion grand cru
non je ne pense pas que les femmes qui
ne savent pas que c'est dangereux
consomme consommer moins de viande crue
et après c'est vrai que c'est moins mal
c'est ce que oui ça fait peut-être ça
serait quand même dans une politique
hygiéniste qui justement de la mesure
sur les 15 à 20 km/heure au politique en
un tabac dans les films etc
et donc voilà c'est la politique réduite
à la taille du pictogramme je pense que
les politiques sont impuissants
le niçois jean résoudre les vrais
problèmes ont choisi d'adhérer duquel
n'ai pas vu la scène les six ans qu'il
est présent à l'elysée vous savez très
bien que la conseillère la conseiller
agriculture et ben vous avez chez vous
l'apprendre donc la conseillère
agriculture à l'enseigné agriculture de
du président de la république
elle était la directrice du lobby du vin
qui s'appelle vin et société et qui
avant d'être à l'elysée faisait campagne
pour l'association interprofessionnelle
à celle ci interprofessionnelle et qui
faisait campagne donc moi ça me tente
pas tout à fait un hasard si nous avons
la foi cette magnifique c'est cette
magnifique tribune de soixante quatre
grands domaines viticoles qui ne vendent
quasiment jamais en france parce que
c'est trop cher pour le peu le public
français en tout cas pour 90 % de la
population et qui d'ailleurs si vous
regardez l'argumentaire que qui est dans
votre journal
est ce qu'ils disent ils disent vous
vous rendez compte nous sommes sains
produits mondialisés ben oui c'est un
produit mondialisé mais de la santé
publique c'est pas le problème des
grands groupes mondialisés c'est
beaucoup de gens rêvent l'industrie du
genre à la traîne la seita faisait
valser leurs secteurs dans le temps
faisait me faisait beaucoup vous voyez
beaucoup d'ouvriers en france c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont tant à la mres
tout le monde sait que je suis au caire
dans ma captivité lecteurs sachez ce jeu
alors je reviens maintenant que les
esprits sans avoir bu moi je tiens à le
dire parce que se sont échauffés
je tiens à dire que c'est une émission
dédiée aux internautes et que nick me
dit tout le monde sait qu'une femme
enceinte ne doit pas boire ni fumer si
les gens sont stupides c'est du
darwinisme sacem
on pourrait faire de dix pattes pareil
dans la malbouffe dans ces cas là
richard bouillon n'a pas eu l'apport
mais c'était pas si le nom donc c'est
bien qu'elle passerait mais je n'avais
pas de références de françois hollande
donc j'ai préféré attendre sur ce coup
là non mais je jamais de faire une
blague et à françois hollande
non non c'est pas possible pas céder
trop fort donc je veux redire sur le
débat en fait il est il y avait enfin il
est intéressant et peut-être plus
important qu'on il qu'on ne le croit
d'abord je pense que si on mettrait bien
moi je ne suis pas opposé à ce qui est
des campagnes de santé publique de
prévention public et qu'elle soit
organisée et qu'à un moment donné elle
vise à mettre sur des produits qui sont
potentiellement dangereux pour des
utilisateurs des avertissements et que
ce soit des avertissements qui soit
plutôt visible et lisible on l'a sur les
paquets de cigarettes je ne trouve pas
ça complètement délirant que ce soit
posée de même que si on trouve que sur
les bouteilles de vin il faut un
meilleur étiquetage pourquoi pas le seul
truc c'est que je comprends ni la
méthode ni le fait de dire que un
centimètre et demi où je sais pas
combien tout d'un coup va faire la
différence terre que autant je pense que
l'internaute qui vous interpeller autant
je pense que l'internaute qui vous
interpellez se trompe en disant que
toutes les femmes savent non toutes les
femmes ne savent pas et je pense qu'il
faut organes total s'annonce une femme
j'ai eu mon premier enfant en 1960 est
évident que je savais qu'il fallait pas
manquer ce parce que vous êtes bien
informé parce que vous allez sur le site
info santé du figaro mais si l'on
ressente et paris
donc je suis allé moi tarzan hervé mais
je suis allé avant cette émission parce
que je suis pas un spécialiste de ce
sujet je suis allé sur le site du
monde.fr et qu'est ce que nous dit le
site du monde
un que ça existe depuis 2007 et donc la
polémique elle est un petit peu
étonnante que deux mais c'est aussi des
bonnes c'est aussi des bonnes sources
d'information dans un pluralisme qui les
lie
j'ai pas françois aussi c'est ça notre
deuxième en 10 kw en fait cette mesure
allait quand même enfin le fait de ne
pas boire pendant qu'on est en elle est
plutôt bien comprise de la part des
français et quand on a des sondages
on a en gros un nombre important de
personnes qui disent que effectivement
il n'est pas bon pour une femme enceinte
de bois ou de fumer ou autre pourtant il
ya une partie qui ne savent pas sur
cette partie là je pense que la ministre
veut veut cibler donc je trouve pas ça
complètement désormais moi c'est la
méthode que je crois enfin en ce moment
c'est là c'est la semaine de colocation
l'impression à la fois sur la maîtresse
d'école
c'est le côté maîtresse écran lcd côté
pourquoi un thème comme ça on est pas
sur une concertation pourquoi sur un
thème comme ça alors que c'est
normalement ça dois je crois aboutir à
la fin de l'année on a des prises et des
préconisations qui doit vous dire
pourquoi sortir maintenant pourquoi elle
sortir comme ça alors qu'elle s'y
pertinemment qu'elle va se taper une
partie des lobbys et qu'elle n'a pas en
face le soutien de ceux qui pourraient
par contre la défendre qui sont
notamment l'ensemble des professions
médicales
hervé nathan je vous donnerai la parole
sur ça mais j'aurais qu'on aborde le
dernier sujet parce qu'on peut pas y
échapper
c'est le foot la france at-elle déjà
gagné c'est bien sûr foot foot voilà un
vrai qu'ici c'est vrai qu'elles sont
importants souvenez vous du mal que
certains joueurs avaient à chanter la
marseillaise c'est en tout cas pas le
cas d'antoine griezmann voici ce qu'a
déclaré ce matin
le joueur français lors de la conférence
de presse il faut être fier d'être
français
voilà on le dit on le dit très peu
voilà on est bien en france on mange
bien on a un beau pays on a une belle
équipe de france on avait beau français
les beaux journalistes et voilà faut
l'être peut être fier d'être français
j'ai envie que les jeunes aussi disent
'voilà vive la france vive la république
bien bien entendu c'était pour la
mention aux journalistes contenait a
justement retransmettre cet ex
rébellions au bois mieux l'on mange cet
extrait d'antoine griezmann
jean-christophe cet intéressant ce que
dit griezmann quand on regarde la
réponse c'est plus sérieusement c'est
intéressant quand on quand on regarde la
réponse que des internautes ont donné à
cette question posée par le figaro.fr
pensez vous que
alors ça c'est la question twitter la
question du figaro.fr c'est pensez vous
que le parcours de l'équipe de france
favorise la cohésion nationale les
internautes ont répondu non à 57 %
moi je pense que si je pars donc de dire
ça je pense que si je pense qu'il faut
pas surinterpréter ce qui est en train
de se passer mais il faut pas bouder son
plaisir de voir un os et un moment
éphémère on est vaccinés on a vu ce que
ça a donné en 1998 où tout est à
merveille on s'est rendu compte que rien
n'était mais loyer que vivre ensemble a
vite a vite disparu donc on sait qu'on
va pas repartir je pense dans ses
délires d'ailleurs n'y a pas tellement
de récupération de l'appropriation de
cette victoire mais au bout de ce moment
de cohésion nationale con qu'on apprécie
qui est joyeuse déjà gagné bien sûr
contre les croates
il ya aucun doute là-dessus façon on l'a
déjà goûté déjà parti sur l'essai sur
les serveurs non mais je pense qu'il ya
vraiment il ya un moment de cohésion
nationale qui vaut ce qu'il vaut encore
une fois c'est pas forcément passé mais
mais mais ça c'est des moments qu'il
faut qu'il faut apprécier pour ce qu'ils
sont encore une fois ce sont les
exagérer mais sans les minimise non plus
en faire la fine bouche sans être
cynique 110 onu tout ça c'est pour rien
c'est des beaufs qui qu'ils sont bourrés
et qui sont contents l'être mais c'est
pas grave si on peut être si on peut
être abandonné heureux abandonné dans sa
vie tous enfants ballon allait webdoc
fait dimanche et lundi ce sera comme
avant
c'est votre avis alexandre oui c'est mon
avis mais chris jean-christophe la
viande il faut pas non plus bouder notre
plaisir il faut pas reproduire les
erreurs de 98 on avait parlé de la
france black blanc beur ou quelques
années plus tard le stade de france
était envahi par de jeunes supporteurs
algériens qui siffler la marseillaise
donc ça c'est une réalité qu'il faut
avoir bien en tête
je crois que le pays est extrêmement
fracturée et que la liesse populaire
traduit aussi malgré tout une envie
d'unité nationale le foot ne suffira pas
mais cette envie de transcendance
collective est un signe je crois que
positif justement il y a
à cet égard cette volonté de cohésion ça
se voit à travers la volonté de se
retrouver sur les sur les grands axes
sur les sur les champs elysées ou bien
sur les grands boulevards
après des victoires ou bien d'aller
partager
le spectacle du match sur les fans zone
or il ya un certain aujourd'hui de
mairie qui ont été sollicités et qui
disent qu'elles ne peuvent pas avoir des
écrans géants parce qu'elles n'ont plus
un an plus d'argent ça c'est une c'est
une évolution par rapport aux années
précédentes richard oui c'est une
évolution sachant qu'on avait déjà connu
par les fans zone fin les fans zone on
les a découvertes un peu avec l'euro
2016 en france mais on a toujours essayé
d'associer depuis très longtemps des
grands écrans géants avec les grandes
manifestations sportives je me rappelle
que frédéric frédérique bredin bien
avant françois hollande quand elle était
ministre des sports avait déjà mis en
place des écrans géants pour les jo de
barcelone et donc il y avait cette envie
déjà de faire partager à la fois dans
des coins qui était très réputée à paris
mais aussi dans des villes de banlieue
dans des villes en province ce moment et
ce temps là finalement on évolue il ya
des contraintes sécuritaires les fans
zone rencontre enfin son la rencontre
entre à la fois le partage de l'émotion
et en même temps des besoins de sécurité
sur ce type d'événement
oui c'est difficile pour des mairies
parce qu'elles ne peuvent pas forcément
les organiser c'est vrai mais en même
temps aujourd'hui les plus belles femmes
zone c les terrasses des cafés les plus
belles fan zone c les rencontres
d'appartements on partage aujourd'hui
davantage et presque plus dans les
terrasses de café qui sont aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avec les vendeur
d'électroménager et les médias ce qui
profite le plus de l'effet immédiat de
la coupe du monde
donc en gros l'économie elle profite à
ce moment là la cohésion nationale dont
vous parlez moi je crois
qu'effectivement il ya besoin à un
moment donné de vivre ses aventures
collectives
il ya besoin d'avoir ce temps de
respiration faut se dire qu'il ya pas
très longtemps
notre pays vivait des moments beaucoup
plus difficile a été dans un moment où
il a fallu passer aussi les cap et se
retrouver pour un moment positif et non
pas forcément
dans des moments qui sont des moments il
faut faire des réponses collectives à
des agressions extérieures je pense que
ça dit beaucoup de ceux qu'on l'attend
et ça nous sommes sûrs nationale
pourquoi deschamps président au quad
deschamps un peu parce que d'une
certaine manière il ya par certains
côtés a dit deschamps c'est un peu
l'anti macron aussi ce soit le meilleur
c'est de montrer que ben d'abord il se
met plutôt derrière son équipe devant
par exemple si évidemment c'est de
garder une vue
être naturellement un leader rappelle
guillaume doizy dans la nature du statut
on a on n'a pas vu chez art le discours
qu'on a eus cher pour eux devant les
armées sur les médias si votre chef avec
les gros yeux par exemple au leader
inter que lui il a déjà été champion du
monde qui est pas aussi les menaces
danse etc
c'est un peu compliqué bien sûr il ya
une limite à l'exercice mais voilà on
trouvait intéressant de ces de
comprendre pourquoi tout le personnage
de didier deschamps parlé à beaucoup de
gens voilà je voulais juste rajouté par
rapport à ce qu'est ce que j'ai ressenti
un drôle de gueule ce que j'ai ressenti
là après la victoire en demi finale
c'est avec cette pièce peut plus leers
et l envie peut-être de dépasser le
moment des attentats
les gens se retrouvent et non pas d'une
grand lièvre nationale ça se fait dans
un moment où ou d'un coup on avait
oublié que c'était ça a était
potentiellement dangereux d'être dans la
rue tous ensemble très nombreux et que
ben voilà on avait un peu subvertit les
dispositifs de sécurité même si elles
étaient très nombreux ils seront très
nombreux mais bien sûr dimanche mais on
dit certaine manière la envie de dire
ben voilà on est toujours religion n'est
déjà pas mal maintenant il va fort bien
falloir s'y coller donc mes pronostics 3
euros avec au moins un but de giroud
j'aurais préféré l'angleterre je dirais
scénario catastrophe à 0 pour la croatie
et sinon 3 0 pour la france aussi si ça
se passe bien
moi je réclame le droit pour ceux qui
s'y connaissent vraiment pas bien de
faire un pronostic
et d'avouer au mois qu' il n'y a pas 60
4 millions de sélectionner en france au
moins 60 camions moisins et moi vu vos
oeuvres
vous êtes obligé de faire un pronostic
mais on n'a pas le droit de retrait
c'est ça mais je suis très mauvais sur
les pronostics donc je vais dire 2 0
pour l'équipe de france mais parce que
j'ai envie que le risque ne prenne pas
de but
prolongations pas de prolongation non
merci beaucoup édition spéciale à partir
de 15h30 dimanche on sera à moscou avec
nos envoyés spéciaux dans l'est
également dans la fanzone à paris et en
plateau les meilleurs spécialistes du
figaro et sport24 autres verticale du
figaro sur sport24 d'ailleurs à suivre
la finale pour la troisième place entre
la belgique et l'angleterre sera demain
soir
et rendez vous
demain dès 9h30 avec figaro live avec à
la barre lui et sylvain châtelain flotte
saint-victor du blog mars attacks on
sera sur les champs elysées également
avec sacha benita qui venez vivre et
commenter avec nous le défilé du 14
juillet et j'en profite pour vous
remercier d'avoir commenté notamment le
foot on va gagner nous dit julien un
match et gagner que lorsqu'il est joué
espérons nous dit avec beaucoup de
sagesse
annie on espère juste que les bleus
auront les armes pour lutter et
remporter ce match et cette coupe
allez les bleus ça je soupçonne de notre
modérateur de vous avoir envoyé alors je
le remercie je remercie infiniment
valentin pilates et je remercie
également toute l'équipe des réseaux
sociaux que vous ne voyez pas et qui
oeuvrent dans l'ombre pour larry sud de
points de vue qui est vraiment une
oeuvre collective je remercie donc marie
amélie putallaz jean baptiste émergents
julie coulon pro fizi valentin pilates
juillet de saint jo et jérémy pont d'yeu
et j'en profite aussi pour remercier nos
interventions les intervenants vous êtes
venus souvent est ici merci d'être
toujours là d'être de dialoguer avec nos
avec les internautes avec notre public
et à ceux qui se démènent également dans
l'ombre charles darche toujours plus
affûtée marie-laëtitia bonavita qui l'on
doit la qualité des intervenants
lorraine trillard et avec l victor
lefebvre
aziliz le corps marieme helie bauchet
pierre matignon et bien sûr toute
l'équipe technique
valérie ensminger charles cousin
benjamin bazin nos 1000 euros 20 turine
fanny adrien finale merci à tous merci
également à guillaume roquette et
marie-amélie lombard la thune la thune
et vous voulez retrouver bien quand on
revient point de vue c'est à dire début
septembre
d'ici là vous restez sur fear alive
parce que les programmes continus
l'actualité elle ne prend jamais de
vacances
[Musique]